that's fantastic I want to say thank you
to all my lads behind me all our
supporter chairman to everybody it was a
was an amazing achievement was was
unbelievable whatever unbelievable
because we want to do something special
but nobody could think about what we
achieve an hour now
now is amazing season for us and I'm
very very pleased how did you celebrate
last night oh nothing nothing
it was a term with my wife and nothing
more I celebrate we speaking with my my
family in Rome and that's it 28 years as
a manager of yeah you've worked with
some of the biggest clubs in the world
yeah when you left them and you have the
time at Greece and you came to Lassiter
did you think your days of possibly
winning any trophies of God look in my
mind always I believed I had to win a
title I want to win I don't know where
but I want to win something and this is
for me is my strength
always I'm positive man and always I
believed that I could achieve something
and then very very pleasing for decent
was there any stage in this career in
this season you told me all season long
next game next game our target is Europe
our target is survival what stage did
you believe that Lester could win this
time though I believe last night Billy
last night really not before no no of
course you feel something you feel Santi
but I am a pragmatic man no and I know
the football very well
something strange could happen the
Tottenham behind has pushed so so well
and I want to say to congratulation to
them because they they made a fantastic
season as well as and for this reason I
I was so so so calm and of course I
believed I believed in my players but
I I was so happy last night
you've said all season long this is a
one-off it's once-in-a-lifetime you said
yeah but can Lester do this again no I
think no but of course we want to
continue to build when I come here the
project was to build to build a very
good foundation and slowly slowly to
grow up together in three four years to
fight for to come in a Europa League and
then rule is ready to come to fight for
Champions League
now decision is out of our project but
of course the the definition are very
very solid we know very well next season
we had to fight for 10th position to go
over but okay we want to do the our best
I'm a positive and then I want to fight
so it's hope 10 target for next season
yes to make a very good campaign in
Europe of coursing in the Cup and also
to be sure and the next season is a save
and make something more you're going to
be in the Champions League next season
yeah this group of players is very very
close-knit the bond between them is
incredible how important now that you
keep these players and that you don't
know the big guy I don't want to serve
nobody and of course if some some
players doesn't want to stay with us
because they aren't happy to continue
with us I don't want unhappy people I
don't want and then we are looking for
reinforce the team but with the same
mentality the same mentality because
this is my mentality this is the dev
mentality will Lincoln felt very very
well together
who comes must know we are working hard
and finally the Premier League trophy
will be presented to you and your
players at the King Power Stadium live
on Sky Sports on Saturday evening how
will that feel I don't know I don't know
I feel good now I feel good now in front
of our fans it would be fantastic it
will be fantastic so they're huge
chelation Hank you've been a real joy
the season thank you very much oh so
much thank you bye